do you have some old jewelry taking up
space in your home well your local
second hand dealer
wants to buy it from you let's head over
to nevada coin mart to see how that
works
what we're going to be doing is we're
going to be using a variety of tests
that are non-destructive now the
importance of that
is this if you have a piece of jewelry
that maybe has been inherited
or passed down a lot of jewelry has
resaleable
value and so we don't want to just start
filing or destroying the jewelry
because it has value as jewelry not just
as scrap
gold weight so we're going to grab this
ring here
now my wife and i we own two 30
000 x-ray spectrometers
an x-ray spectrometer is a
non-destructive test
that tells us the exact material content
the ring is 13.17
carat or 54.86 percent
gold now the reason that that is
important
is because gold 14 karat can be
between 54 and 58 percent
and so what happens is this when you do
the scratch testing
they will tell you that it's not 14
karat because it's not
true 14 karat and so they're going to
say it's at least 10
but it's not 14 and so you're going to
get paid on the 10 carat value
we buy this as 14 karat gold because it
is 14 karat gold
if it is that we're going to pay the
best price one of the ways that we are
able to do that is to buy it as
resaleable jewelry so it doesn't have
file marks and acid and all these
ridiculous things
let's talk about the coin that you have
now
this is an american buffalo now this
coin
in order to be real needs to be 24 karat
gold
one of the ways that we pay the most is
by being on top of our game
and so what you can see is that this is
24 karat gold
now they make plated
that will fake that so now what do you
what do you do well we have the precious
metal verifier
now what the precious metal verifier
does
is this test to make sure that the gold
content is all the way through
and so when the coin is in green what
it's saying
is that the gold is all the way through
because we buy sell and trade
when we sell to the customer we want to
ensure that we're giving them
what it is as well we're also fully
transparent
with the price of gold we look at the
new york
spot price of gold to give the client
the very best price
for more information call 702-998-4000
or visit
neobiz.com we'll be right back